only moments ago former president Donald
Trump wrapped up his speech for
Mar-A-Lago now the president pointed out
a history all the unfairness
unprecedented frankly that he has faced
since coming down that escalator at
Trump Tower now one man has no one man
has ever been subjected to anything like
this in the history of this country the
media colluded along with the Democrats
to destroy him from day one the
president laid out what he did
successfully as president it was a
powerful case and he also laid out that
this is a nation in Decline and five
presidents combined could not mess the
country up more than Joe Biden he also
talked about investigations that never
ever seemed to go away his the entire
time since he came down that escalator
never stops take a look
[Music]
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it
and now this massive election
interference at a scale never seen
before in our country
beginning with the radical left George
Soros back prosecutor Alvin Bragg of New
York
[Applause]
that he would get
president Trump I gotta get him I'm
gonna get him this is a guy campaigning
you want to get president Trump at any
cost and this before he knew anything
about me didn't know a thing about me he
was campaigning
as it turns out virtually everybody that
has looked at this case including rhinos
and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime
and that it should never have been
brought
everybody
all right let us be very clear here
today Alvin Bragg charged Donald Trump
with 34 felony counts of falsifying
documents surrounding legal ndas
non-disclosure agreements from 2016. now
per New York state code these are
usually misdemeanor crimes five years
past the statute of limitations but
through a novel legal Theory never
before tried Alvin Bragg is now
attempting to elevate the expired
misdemeanors to felonies to try and
prove intend to commit yet another crime
an election crime is believed to be a
federal election crime that likely has
also passed the statute of limitations
and by the way outside of his purview
and that basically the FEC and the doj
they both decided there was no crime
they never indicted the president we had
the former head of the FEC on this very
program saying no that's not a crime and
here's the kicker album Bragg won't even
specify what those other crimes are in
the indictment now why on Earth wouldn't
the D.A need to have to prove these
other Phantom crimes or at least
identify what they are this sounds
insane this sounds crazy it sounds like
a Banana Republic but they are bogus
charges and yes another Witch Hunt and
to make matters worse the bulk of brag's
charges they depend on testimony from
that guy who is an an ex-con convicted
liar or admitted liar and felon Michael
Cohn and here's Cohen's former legal
adviser Bob Costello now he's not a
convict he's not a an admitted liar and
guess what I think he's going to be a
powerful counter to the Alvin Bragg star
witness that would be Michael Cohen you
decide
what do you have on Donald Trump and
that's when he started with the same
litany that he used for the rest of the
two hours I swear to God Bob I don't
have anything on Donald Trump but the
point is when somebody is is really
thinking of committing suicide and
you're offering them a legal way out of
this if he had any information about
Donald Trump that would have been the
one time even for a Serial liar like
Michael Cohen to to fess up and say well
I know this or that because I'm I want
to save my own hide but he didn't do
that Michael Cohn who as I said before
was pacing back and forth would suddenly
stop in the middle of whatever he was
talking about and turn and point his
finger at us and say I want you guys to
understand I will do whatever the f I
have to do I will never spend a day in
jail he said that at least 10 to 20
times during that two-hour period it was
it was a bizarre Mantra but it made it
clear to us that Michael Cohn was saying
I will lie cheat steal shoot someone I
will never spend a day in jail
all right pay attention to what he said
here he said do you have anything on
Michael Cohen if you want to prevent
yourself from going to jail I have
nothing Bob I have nothing at all but
I'm never going to jail he said he's
suicidal and I'll do whatever it takes
to not go to jail now not only did
Costello destroy the credibility of the
state star witness Michael Cohn but cone
himself completely contradicted the
state's case look at this statement this
is 2018. now this indictment talks about
payments in 2017. I'll ask Joe takapina
and Mark Levin about it in a minute
quote in a private transaction in 2016 I
use my own personal funds to facilitate
a payment of a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars to miss Stephanie
Clifford AKA Stormy Daniels neither the
Trump organization nor the Trump
campaign was a party to the transaction
the payment to miss Clifford was lawful
and was not a campaign contribution or a
campaign expenditure by anyone now Cohn
attorney echoed those very same remarks
in a letter to the FEC February of 2018
keep that date in your mind in a private
transaction in 2016 before the U.S
presidential election Mr Cohen used his
own personal funds to facilitate a
payment of a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars to miss Stephanie Clifford
neither the Trump organization or the
Trump campaign was a party to the
transaction with Miss Clifford and
notice the date again 2018 February
Alvin Bragg refers to payments from
2017. now again this is a pathetically
weak case based on an ex-con and
admitted liar and everyone knows it
maybe except Alvin Bragg but of course a
grand jury they can indict a ham
sandwich and Alvin Bragg is not so good
at getting convictions in fact he has
one of the lowest conviction rates in
the entire country hovering at an
embarrassing 50 percent now that's for
felony cases that he actually tries
however 52 percent of all felonies they
are downgraded to misdemeanors under
Bragg Donald Trump gets the distinction
of being the only person that he's
accusing of a misdemeanor that they're
raising it to 34 felonies now
mysteriously it went uh the other way
with President Trump and the former
president's charges were upgraded then
multiplied through what is a risky and
very complicated legal maneuver I don't
believe they will be successful but
however there are so many legal issues
out there it makes you wonder does this
ever stop remember while violent
offenders are walking all over the
streets of New York misdemeanors that
Trump what can serve 134 years according
to one report in prison for allegedly
mislabeling a few documents according to
Alvin Bragg this is more than warranted
because document crimes are so so
important this is what he said today
true and accurate business records are
important everywhere to be sure
they are all the more important in
Manhattan
the financial center of the world
that is why we have a history in the
Manhattan DA's Office of vigorously
enforcing white-collar crime
now uh sure Alvin Bragg lets rape us
drug dealers armed robbers out out of
jail with a slap on the wrist no bail
but those victimless document crimes now
that's real serious stuff uh why lie
Alvin why don't you just be honest about
your intentions we all know what's
happening here Bragg is just fulfilling
his own campaign promise to go after one
man that's former president Trump one
organization the Trump organization one
family the Trump family on the campaign
Trail he boasted about suing Trump more
than a hundred times patted himself on
the back for investigating Trump Trump's
children he ran as the self-proclaimed
Trump expert now obviously the focus of
his campaign was not making New York a
safer place it was getting Donald Trump
watch
I know a lot of people are wondering uh
whoever has this job
are they going to convict Donald Trump
but that that that is uh the number one
issue the times calls brag a talented
prosecutor whose successful suit with
the Trump Foundation could be invaluable
experience but the investigation he'll
take over as the chief Deputy attorney
general in New York state I oversaw some
of the office's biggest cases from
exposing illegal Behavior by the Trump
Foundation we know there's a trump
investigation I have investigated Trump
and his children and held them
accountable for their misconduct with
the Trump Foundation I also sued the
Trump Administration more than a hundred
times we know that the D.A is
investigating uh Trump uh when I was at
the AG's office I sued Trump over a
hundred times for his administration's
misconduct and brought a case against
the Trump foundation and held him
accountable
well we have let's say a D.A doing this
an attorney general doing this in the
state of the New York going after one
person one family one organization now
in a fair jurisdiction in this case that
would be thrown out because of what is
called prosecutorial misconduct but this
is New York City Manhattan where 90
percent of Voters they just hate Donald
Trump you think he can get a fair trial
in New York City but don't expect the
judge to change the venue this
particular judge well likely hates
Donald Trump like everyone else in New
York uh he was already very heavy-handed
with the former CFO of the Trump
organization who is now in Rikers Island
over you know minor tax violations in
other words this won't be a fair trial
and sadly this is probably just the
beginning this is going to be a long
tsunami of looming charges against Trump
right in the middle of far left
jurisdictions across the country now if
you're a conservative the three places
or you probably don't want to be
involved legally New York City City
Washington D.C and Fulton County Georgia
guest three what three jurisdictions
Donald Trump will be dealing with and by
the way also add to that a frivolous
civil suit from a woman named e Gene
Carroll alleging some type of sexual
assault from the 1990s according to USA
Today she doesn't remember the exact
year but she's claiming that she was a
victim of a sexual assault in a changing
room at a huge department store around
somewhere around 27 years ago but she
doesn't quite remember in coordination
with activist judges prosecutors
Democrats they are I think the president
is right this is their attempt to
distract completely one candidate from
the 2024 election is that interference
you decide by using the courts as a
political weapon that's certainly novel
now in doing so they're trying literally
turning the country into a Banana
Republic you know where what Hunter
Biden can reportedly take money and make
deals with China and Russia and Ukraine
how much money did the Biden family make
with Russia how much were these business
deals with China how much money did
Hunter actually make in Ukraine and what
about the Dozen countries that James
Comer has been talking about and out of
the business Deals they made how much
money did they did they themselves take
did they pay taxes on all of that money
did they always cut out 10 percent of
for the big guy or as Hunter complained
on his laptop uh he pays half his income
to Pops as anyone faced consequences
your FBI has had that laptop from hell
since December 2019. does that sound
like equal justice and application of
our laws in America a country where what
Jim Comey is an FBI director can take a
fisa application where it says on the
very top verified sign his name to it
and not only was the information not
verified it was unverifiable and he
signed it three separate times wouldn't
that be committing fraud against the
court lying to a judge and ended up and
resulted in spying on an American
presidential candidate and president no
consequences at all whatsoever we live
in a country now where Hillary Clinton
can mishandle top secret classified
information then wipe the evidence clean
with something called bleach bit
something none of us had heard of up to
that point and never see the inside of a
courtroom no reasonable prosecutor would
ever prosecute according to Comey but
Comey of course now exposed himself oh
today's a good day the day that Donald
Trump got indicted if you are a
republican a conservative or if your
last name is Trump and you so much as
spit on the sidewalk or jaywalk you
better brace yourself because the strong
arm of the law is coming for you and
it's sad to say but there's not Justice
in America tonight as it should be that
we don't have equal justice we don't
have equal application of our laws and
guess what when you don't have both you
might as well take your con institution
and shred it because every law is based
on that one important document now of
course when you have a fair trial with
the jury of your peers or are you going
to have to go into a venue where nine
out of 10 people don't like your
political leanings you know what do you
believe in free speech do you believe in
free and fair elections anyway as we
speak Democrats are now spitting on our
constitution for cheap political gain
and mark my words if they get away with
it this great country that we love that
so many people fought bled and died for
as the Great America Republic will never
be the same again hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else